thank you so much you guys are already
one of the nicest crowds I've gotten to
perform for I'll explain so I grew up on
welfare my mom was a single parent five
kids no child support and a lot of
people find that hard to believe that I
was ever that poor I think it's because
the way I look like I look like
everything just like worked out in fact
I look like the guy in the movie that
yells don't you know who my father is
and I legitimately don't I know who he
is but not like who he is you miss out
on certain things as a poor kid like we
never had ice cream growing up the
closest thing we had to ice cream and I
hesitate to even call it that is every
once in a while my mom would buy us that
like giant clear value bucket of ice
cream do you remember those but they
were like too cheap to even be a real
flavor we have white and we have darker
white this is true my mom only bought us
that ice cream because she needed the
bucket
at Walmart a mopping bucket cost $6.99
value bucket of ice cream $4.99 it was
cheaper than an empty bucket do you know
how shitty your ice cream has to be
great to actually depreciate the value
of an empty bucket that means people
were like I don't want that bucket if
ice creams been in there it might ruin
my dirty mop water some food though way
too expensive who the hell does avvocato
think it is you know we grow those here
right yet every restaurant you go into
avocados like guys just so you know I'm
always the dollar extra oh sure sure
sure you could just buy me in the store
but even then you really can't eat me
until I'm ready Oh whoopsie Daisy doo
dee doo did you just fall asleep for 10
minutes because in that time I've taken
it upon myself to go ahead and die yes
now it tastes like wet car keys
meanwhile bananas only grow in Central
America they cost negative 11 cents you
make money buying bananas
not only will rapport I also grew up in
a big family so that meant I had to do a
lot of things I didn't want to do just
because it saved my mom like a little
bit of time like one summer my two older
sisters they went to this cheerleading
day camp now five minutes up the road
was the boys basketball camp that I
really want to go to but because my mom
didn't want to drive the extra five
minutes every day she decided oh you
should just attend the cheerleading camp
with your sisters basically the same
thing those are two wildly different
things that's like if you were in a
restaurant and you tried to order a coke
and this server was like oh actually I
we don't have coke but is it okay if I
just frame you for arson typically the
same so I go to his cheer camp miserable
but eventually I make it to the boys
basketball camp because at the end of
the summer the big grand finale for us
gals
is we get to go up to the boys camp to
cheer them on during one of their games
so we walk up there and before the boys
can even take the court we have to show
them what we learned over the summer so
we start them off it's probably our most
masculine cheer which just starts with
all right boys show us what you got show
us what you got boys show us what you
got
now I don't know if you've ever had to
cheer someone on as they bully you but
it's a lot like if someone shot you and
then it was your job to reload their gun
for them don't worry it gets worse
halftime rolls around now we have a
cheer with some participation built in
we have the cheer that goes we got
spirit how about you and then the boys
are supposed to go yeah and then we go
they can't do and then they go yeah even
louder so I step out I go we got spirit
how about you and then the boys take
this opportunity to yell cheer queer and
then I have to chime back in but I can't
hear you
so in terms of audiences you guys are
one of the nicer ones I've gotten to
perform for it thank you so much
[Applause]
you